when it comes to MMOs you can't get any
bigger than World of Warcraft and every
new release is a giant expansion of
cataclysmic proportions the latest
expansion is no different bringing new
lands levels and lore even better you'll
be able to play it this year Legion
releases on August 30th first and
foremost Legion raises the level cap to
110 and if you feel like grinding again
you can do it with the new demon hunter
class you can also explore a brand new
continent the broken Isles the region is
packed with new artifact weapons
dungeons and raids PvP is also getting a
revamp you can pre-order the expansion
for an instant level 100 character boost
and early access to the demon hunter
class Legion will cost you 50 bucks but
there's also a digital deluxe edition
available for 70 that bundle includes
content for other Blizzard games like
heroes of the storm and diablo 3 a $90
collector's edition will be exclusive to
retail but picking that up gets you an
artbook behind the scenes blu ray/dvd
combo soundtrack mousepad and all the
content from the digital deluxe edition
that's a lot of material and a lot of
options but you have until the end of
august to make your choice and for all
of blizzards world of warcraft
announcements you're ready in the right
place